And now it's the old scout master.
Hey, we were off to our camping trip and I was driving along and I noticed that the horn
on my van wasn't working.
So I pulled over and I popped the hood and of course the scouts got out and they were
looking around and checking it out and things like that.
I found a loose wire on the horn and we hooked it back up, got in and the scouts
you know said, well, did you get the horn fixed? and I said, yes,
Beep repaired,
Beep repaired.
Oh yeah,
If you know a better joke, send it in, would you please?
I could obviously use some help.
Hey, this is podcast number 195..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and once again, pretty full again this week.
Matthew Malendick is from Canal Fulton, Ohio, with Troop 915 and he wrote in to
say this. I just listened to podcast 194 regarding Eagle Scouts.
As always, your view and opinion sheds light on topics that I am wrestling with.
We have a group of scouts that are progressing quickly through their advancement.
Several of these scouts, I believe, will reach Eagle.
Each year our scouts plan the activities calendar for the upcoming year and I'm trying very hard
to guide the boys through the process of making their decisions.
So we are scouting and, quoting Babin Powell, I try to remember: the Scout Master must be
alert to check badge hunting as compared to badge earning.
Your description of advancement and the requirements for Eagle has helped clear
my mind and allowed me to remember.
If there are any questions by the time a scout reaches Eagle, it's really not the
fault of the scout, but the questions should fall on the adult leaders.
Thanks for all you do and I look forward to the podcast each week.
Well, thank you, Matt. thanks for being in touch. thanks for your encouraging words.
I'm glad this is making sense.
Mike Marty wrote in again this week. we heard from him last week. he said thanks for the
reply and for reading my email on the last podcast.
Mainly, thank you for making me a better scouter.
Last night at the committee meeting I was asked to give an update on the Troop.
I had just listened to your podcast on Eagle Scouts and shared it with the committee.
It went over very well.
We have three Scouts working on their Eagle projects.
Two of the boys are special need Scouts who were told in another crew they would never
be allowed to advance to Eagle.
Oh my, isn't that a shame.
It was nice to have your thoughts to reinforce the direction we're going with our Troop.
If there's anything I can do to help repay all that you've done for me and my Scouts,
please ask and the answer will be yes.
First of all, thanks so much.
I'm glad that we're able to be of assistance to you and good on you for working with
those Scouts who may have been misunderstood and turned down in another unit.
That's really a shame.
And to answer your question, is there anything you can do to help?
Well, keep listening.
Mark and San Diego, a good old friend of the podcast, wrote in to say first,
good song in the middle of the podcast.
It will work well for an upcoming slideshow
And he's talking about Born to Be a Scout by Alex Boyer. that was in podcast 194..
I get questions about the music I use on a regular basis
And if you'll go to the archive page at scoutmastercgcom, there you will find
a little Amazon widget that contains a lot of the different, where you'll be able
to get the full length version of some of the music clips that I use.
Mark went on to say as the father of one of those 50% Eagles that people
could state an issue with. I obviously agree with your point of view
expressed in podcast 194.
My son was far from the most organized scout.
I recall how haphazardly he had his backpack packed when we went to
Fillmont two summers ago.
However, today he is the one in his own apartment who knows how to cook
And he is the one taking leadership in organizing and coordinating study
groups at his college, Texas A&M.
I know many other Scouts from our troop that come closer to that idealized
Eagle than my son.
However, I know the process he went through in seven years of scouting,
including intaining Eagle status,
And that helped him immeasurably to get where he is today. so far
Am I a proud dad,
You bet,
And I am an appreciative dad as well.
Mark, first of all, thanks for getting back in touch
And thanks for the update,
And I think every father feels a little bit like you do.
Of course we're proud of our sons,
Of course we're proud of what they do and we want to be supportive.
But we know, we know, don't we?
But you know, if a boy goes through the process of scouting,
if he goes through that scouting journey, there are things that
start to pay dividends right away
And there are some things that aren't going to
We're not going to see the result of until they're off on their own
And you'll be able to draw a direct line back to some of the things
that they did in scouting and you'll go, wow, you know, I'm so
pleased that we took the time and we made sure that that was part of our lives.
Mike Scaiuta is the Scoutmaster of Troop 706 in the Great Rivers
Council in Columbia, Missouri,
And he wrote in to say first I want to thank you for the encouragement
and ideas you share.
I took over a Scoutmaster this fall and have implemented a lot of changes
around the patrol method and scout led adult coached leadership.
I even stole one of your ideas for our Weebelow's open house and
pulled a couple of scouts without much warning into the
meaning to answer questions from Weebelow's parents.
The feedback was awesome.
As for last week's podcast, I was really interested about the
letter from the scouter who was asked to put together a tender
foot to first class program for their district.
I agreed with his assessment and yours, but it got me wondering
about the ubiquitous Brown Sea type trail to first class summer
camp programs at which so many first year scouts get many of
their requirements signed off.
On the plus side, those programs are typically staffed by older
Scout staffers, but it still avoids using the patrol method,
Does it not?
I have a similar reaction to some of the things like merit
badge colleges that are growing increasingly common these days.
I think it may take away from the learning experience a scout
has of contacting a merit badge instructor and arranging
schedules and working through the material with a small
group or individually.
First of all, thanks for the encouraging words and I'm glad
you listened last week and you found what we had to say
useful.
You know, I think it's really important to keep emphasizing
that advancement happens naturally within a troop that
uses the patrol method.
Patrols should be doing everything together.
Now, boys that go to summer camp for their first year and
they go to the kind of Brown Sea Island kind of program-
Ours is called the trailblazer program- where they do a heavy
concentration on skills up to first class.
I think those programs are great.
I don't know that the requirements should be signed
off in them.
I know that that does not happen where we go to camp,
but the scouts are exposed to the skills that they're
going to need throughout the year with the troop and they
have a chance to refine them a little bit
And then when they're back with us and in the context of
their patrol they can demonstrate those skills and
get them signed off.
So you know that works for me.
It's not too hard to find people who will debate with
you about merit badge colleges and those other
kind of mass events where merit badges are offered
to large groups by a single counselor.
I'm not the counselor there.
I wouldn't necessarily have the time or inclination
to be a counselor at one of those big events myself.
But if people are doing that and scouts are earning merit
badges and it's all above board and everything's
everybody's happy and things are being learned.
And you know I have a hard time arguing
with the experience.
I know my scouts go to museums and different merit
badge opportunities
And, like you said, they seem to be getting more and
more prevalent and I think it's great.
My job is just to make sure that they're working
with a trained counselor and to keep a half eye
open to make sure that that counselor is following
their training.
But you know, over the past several years, as we
have had more and more of our scouts do that. I
haven't really seen a problem.
I've been a little skeptical, like you, but I've
never really seen a problem with those events.
And finally, we heard this week from Robert
Glazier. He said: I have just made a token
contribution towards your expenses in producing
the blog and the podcast.
Scoutmasterscgcom is a tremendous resource
and I sincerely appreciate the effort you put
into it. Very best regards.
And Rob is the Scoutmaster of Troop 18
in Muskego, Wisconsin.
Well, Rob, thank you so much.
I can't tell you what it means to me when
people go out of their way to contribute
to making the podcast and the blog and all
the other stuff possible.
And I want to take a few moments to talk
about that, because today I am launching
a couple of different things.
I have three things to talk to you about.
First of all, over the past several podcasts
I've been promising and promising that my new
book, The Scouting Journey, would soon be
ready for publication
And I am happy to tell you we're ready
to accept pre-publication orders
for that book through our backer program.
Let me tell you a little bit about the
backer program.
I started the blog about eight years ago
in the podcast a couple of years later,
And what was kind of a fun sideline,
you know kind of a hobby has- has turned
into something more like a full-time
occupation.
If you go to the backer page at
scottmastercgcom- and I'll make sure to
link it to the post that contains this
podcast- you'll get an idea of the time
that I spend and the costs that are
involved and how you can help.
Very simply, what I have done is I've
created a number of premiums for
different backer payments that will go
to help defray the annual costs of
presenting the blog and the podcast and
all the other resources that we work
with, the videos and all that type of
thing. Our audience is growing every
single week and that's a wonderful
thing. As the audience grows, the costs
of server space and getting these
things out to people, that grows too.
I won't go into all the details but
let me just repeat:
We have a backer program through the
backer program for a contribution
towards defraying those expenses.
I've got several premiums for you and
one of them is an autographed copy of
my new book, The Scouting Journey,
And I got to tell you I'm pretty
excited about the book.
I am really happy with the way that
it came out and I hope you'll go
take a look. There's a synopsis of
the book that I published just today
on the scottmastercgcom,
So do go and make sure to get a
look at it. If the backer program
doesn't appeal to you, the book will
be available for purchase on
amazoncom on November 30th,
So that's just a couple of weeks
away. If you're interested in
helping support the blog and the
podcast, consider becoming a
backer. Go to scottmastercgcom
to find out how.
So, first of all, the backer
program. second of all, the release
of my new book, The Scouting Journey.
and third, I have a little bit of a
stealth announcement that I'm only
making here on the podcast.
If you have a mobile device that
uses Android, you can go to
Google Play right now, search
for ScoutmasterCG and you will
find that I've created a new
mobile app. This is one of the
projects I've been working on for
a couple of weeks. It's a free app
and on the app you'll be able to
access all the additions of the
Scoutmaster podcast. You'll be
able to read the blog and the
Twitter feed and our Facebook
feed and be able to contact us
using the app. I'm looking at
adding some other features to it,
but making this announcement on
the podcast is kind of a stealth
announcement, because we're still
kind of in that beta stage where
we're trying to sort things out.
So if you have a mobile device
that uses Android and an app
that gives you access to all the
podcasts and all the other things
I've spoken about interest, you
Go to Google Play, download the
app, try it out for a while,
Tell me what you think of it and
you'll be one of my app beta
testers. As soon as we go
through this development phase, we
will also release the app to
iTunes. There's a little bit more
involved with that and it's a
little more costly to get the app
on iTunes, but it'll be ready to
go on iTunes as soon as we've
gone through this beta testing
phase. Well, that's a lot of news
for one week, isn't it?
I'll tell you it's been a bit
of a challenge setting all this
up and getting things ready to
go. I'm not a software person,
You know. I don't have any
formal training or anything like
that. I have to kind of pick my
way along. So all of this,
all of this stuff has been set
up with, you know, bailing
wire and a little bit of twine,
and I struggled a lot
putting the payment process
together for the backer program.
So I hope it works.
The app was a little bit easier,
but still a bit of a challenge
to get that going. So so that's
what I've been busy with the
past several weeks. Please take
advantage of those resources
and let me know what you
think of them. This podcast is
going to be probably on the
brief side because we've been
putting a lot of times into these
other initiatives. We just
recorded the scout circle
for November last night,
And when I say we, I mean
me. it was a solo performance
And we talked about the
transition from weeblos to
Boy Scouts, And you can go
check that out at scout circle
dot org. unless you're tired
of hearing me drone on and
on and on.
You can see a picture of me.
It's, it's a video.
So if that does anything
for you, our monthly
scout circle was last night.
It's been recorded,
It's up. I appreciate those of
you who watched and who's
sending questions.
Well, the remainder of this
podcast is going to be taken
up with a couple of email
questions we received over the
past week. If you send an
email question in and you
haven't gotten an answer yet
or you haven't heard it on the
podcast, don't. don't despair,
I'm working my way through a bit
of a backlog right now.
I've got a couple that I
think will interest you for
this podcast, So let's get
started. shall we
Email? that is folks?
And here's an answer to one of
your emails.
Christina is a scout parent out
in Pacifica, California, and
she got in touch with me to
ask this question.
My son is new to Boy Scouts.
He started going on more
overnights and I would like to
get him a good backpack.
I read your article about
packs and have a question.
First, my son is 12 years old.
He's four foot nine and it
weighs about 78 pounds.
I did find a place to buy the
Outdoor Products Dragonfly pack
and I should take a moment
here to explain that that has
been one of my favorite packs.
It's a external frame pack.
It's a great pack for Scouts.
It's relatively inexpensive and
it was widely available up until
this summer and I've had
difficulty being able to find
it. but apparently it's showing up
again. And Christina goes on to
say: would you suggest going with
that pack or with the other one
I saw on your site, the Teton
Sports Scout 3400 or
the Scouts Explorer
4000.. Some of our Scouts swear
by internal frame packs, but
I know it depends on what
they want. Thank you in advance
for any guidance you can provide.
One of the key pieces of gear
any scout needs
is a decent backpack.
My favorite one for years
and years was the Outdoor Products
Dragonfly.
It's an external frame pack.
It's very adjustable and
this past year I discovered the
Teton Sports internal frame
packs. Now, neither of
these packs are what you would call
extraordinarily high end
kind of packs, but
they are both less than $100
a piece. I think the Dragonfly
comes in around $50 or $60
and the two Teton packs
are in the range of $65
to $75.. That's
a great deal. Now, if you want to
take a look at the Teton packs,
go to
scoutmastercgcom
and look in the gear section for a
video review of those two packs.
Some of our Scouts bought them
this year. They love them. They think they're great.
So, Christina,
you're looking for advice or an answer
about which to get. First of all,
with a 12 year old who's 4 foot
9 and weighs 78 pounds,
the most important thing is getting
him a pack that will fit. Both the
Dragonfly and the Teton
Sports Scout 3400
are adjustable enough to fit
a very small frame, So they
will work for you
As far as which one to get
boy, it's really a toss up.
If your son is
not like a typical 12 year old
and he's a very organized packer
and things like that, then the internal
frame packs going to work great for him.
He'll be able to use that for the next several years.
if he's not all that organized,
then you might want to go with the external
frame pack because
they're a little bit easier to pack
and keep track of your stuff- at least
that's my experience with them-
and that one too, widely
adjustable and we should be good
for several years of use. So,
Christina, I hope that helps.
this email came from Ever Young,
who is the scout master of Troop
31 in Connorsville, Indiana,
and he said: my question may sound
a little weird, but I have not seen
this taught or how to
handle the particular situation I find
myself in. We're a new unit
and we're coming on our one year
birthday in December. Well, first of all,
congratulations. We have 19 scouts
right now and the challenge is
is that all of our scouts are between the
age of 10 and a half to 13.
I've read countless articles
on the patrol method.
we're progressing towards that,
but we're far from it, to be honest
and I know that this really isn't
the way it's supposed to be. In the last
two months, scouts have taken total
responsibility for the troop activity at each
meeting, so at this point they take care
of the opening and the closing and announcements,
but I still take care of a lot
of pieces of the meeting. It feels like
we're progressing, but I know
I'm still doing more than I'm supposed to do.
I have to say the scouts have come
a long way from where we started
and they're really doing great.
we have so many things on the horizon.
the way things are coming together and the support
we're getting from the community and our parents
is very heartening. We're anticipating
7 to 10 more boys in February
through April. So I
am feeling the overwhelming need
to improve our application
of the patrol method. I'm just a little
worried about doing it with such
young scouts. It seems to
me like if we were a more mature troop
with boys age
15 to 17, it would be easier.
Is there anything I can do
differently to accelerate our
application of the patrol method, or is it
just going to be a process until the boys mature
some more? Well, Everett, thanks
for getting in touch and you're asking a
really important question because
I know that a lot of people who are listening
often are coming from
newer units and
units where the boys are relatively
young, between the ages of 10 and a half
and 13.. Now this matters
to some extent, but let's all
remember that any scout master's
job is to be a responsive
leader. Your involvement
in what goes on in the troop
changes as your scouts
gain more confidence and skill.
you respond
to their confidence and skill.
I liken the process to someone
tying a square knot. I'll show
them how to tie it. I put the rope in
their hands and I let them give it a try.
If they get it, we're good.
now they know what to do. They can go
around tying square knots all over the place.
if they struggle a bit,
I'm not going to immediately just
take the rope away from them and show them
again. I'll talk to them.
I'll coach them through the whole thing. you know, left over right,
right over left,
but the rope stays in their hands.
if they're completely at sea,
if they can't even get started, I'll
ask for the rope back and
show them again. The same
thing works for engaging
scouts in leadership
and getting the patrol system off
the ground. What's the best way to
learn to tie a square knot. We'll have somebody
show you, So there will be a part
in the process where the scout
master has to show them how things
work and then, once they've
seen how things work-
just like tying that square knot-
you're going to put the rope in their
hands, so to speak. let them at it. let
them actually lead, make them
responsible for things and then
coach them and let them work at it.
it's much more complex and layered
than something as simple as tying a square
knot, but I think the same concepts
apply When we're dealing with
youth leaders. all of us are going
to be in those three stages
where we're showing them things, where we're
coaching them through things and where we're
just letting them do things
in all kinds of different things at different
times. I will tell you this:
in my experience, most of us
hold onto the rope a little bit longer than
we need to. We should let go
and let them at it. Now.
you've shown them how to run the rest of the meeting
a few times. maybe it's their turn
to try it. Don't wait until you think
they're mature enough, because that is
a shifting standard.
if you're like me, they're never
going to be exactly mature enough to please
you. There was a time, as a scout master,
when I looked at a boy who was 15,, 16,
17 years old. I thought these guys
are really mature and responsible
and advanced. and years
and years later, after working with dozens
and dozens and dozens of
15,, 16, and 17 year olds,
they're not all that mature
to me.
So that standard might shift,
I think. instead of looking
for maturity, look for the excitement
and the engagement
of them doing things
for themselves. They won't do
it as well as you, That's
a given. They won't do a very
good job of it to begin with.
Things may not look like they're moving ahead
at all. They may look like
they're moving backwards, But
if you hold on to the rope,
they're never going to get to give this a try.
So keep a half eye on what they do,
because if you hover over them,
they'll be watching you. instead of doing
what they need to do and then ask them
after it's done how it went.
There's where you get to coach a little in small steps
and you build on things
a little at a time. They'll surprise you
with how much they can do
and how well they get things done.
And let's face it every once in a while-
it's just going to be a total mess.
You'll work hard to find
that one little glimmer of hope
in the total mess and you'll congratulate them
on that. and then you'll work with them
to start a discussion about how things
could have gone better. Like I said,
of course, we're better leaders and instructors
than any 12 to 15 year old and,
for the most part, any 15 to
20 year old, So watching them
can be a little painful. You'll want
to step in and fix things,
but don't you dare Think of yourself
as a scientist studying animals
in their habitat or an orthologist
looking at birds. Stay back,
Don't let them catch you watching
or they're going to get spooked. You'll learn
a lot from what you see.
Let them do their best, congratulate
them on it and then ask them if there's
any way that things could have gone better.
Don't preach, don't try and teach them
anything. Just have a conversation
and talk with them and
listen to their answers carefully.
I gotta tell you this really
works, even when it looks like it doesn't.
Keep your eye on what your scouts are
actually doing. rather than measuring
how well they do it,
Encourage them, support them
and make the most of every opportunity,
and you've got to be patient with yourself,
as you're learning how to do this too,
Everett, I hope that helps. Thanks for getting
in touch. You can get in touch
with me and you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much
for listening to this edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
While you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email. You can also
subscribe to the podcast on iTunes,
and when you do leave a comment or review
or rating, you can access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at Stitchercom. As I announced
earlier in this podcast, if you have
an Android mobile device, you can
also access the podcast
through the new ScoutmasterCG
app. You'll find it on Google Play.
It's still in the beta
stages, folks, so don't expect too much,
but go take a look, download the app,
try it out and let me know what you think
Now, if that's not enough for you. well, you
experience all the wonders of the vast
ScoutmasterCGcom complex
through the never-ending shifting panorama
of social media outlets.
join the 4300 other folks
who follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
join our 860
Twitter followers on Twitter.
watch us at ScoutmasterCG on
YouTube and, for admittance
to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle,
join the 400 odd other folks
at ScoutmasterCG on
Google+. That's not to say that folks
who use Google plus are odd.
Well, I don't know. maybe,
anyway,
if all of that doesn't make any sense at all,
if none of that appeals to you, I'll tell
you what Bunky you can zoom into
the late 90s and send me an email.
that's right, that electronic mail,
and you can get in touch with me at this
email address. it's Clark CLA
RKE
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
that's Clark CLA
RKE
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
and now a message from the legal department.
the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America, nor are they endorsed or
sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, before we leave
let's talk to our founder, Sir Robert
Baden-Pel. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping,
why? thank you, sir, until next time.
bye, everyone.